I'm here with who better retire in
Berlin and he treats patients with all
things and he has written a book about
it thanks for having me today
M fascia are parts of the connective
tissue why are they so important fascia
wrapped and connected everything all
structures in the human body every
muscle every organ has a facial wrapping
and the fascia gives our body its shape
and supports it so they're very
important to give the body support at
the same time they're elastic and act as
shock absorbers they're also responsible
for making organs and muscles light on
each other
and at the same time they're highly
integrated with nerve endings so they
also form a communications network in
the body and you say that those fascia
can stick together and can get some kind
of gurgling yeah so why is that a
problem it's a problem because wherever
fashion becomes stuck and glued there is
a lack of motion of movement and where
there's no movement there's pain and why
do they get glued in the first place
fash I get glued or hardened whenever
there's a lack of movement or when they
are under constant stress and with
Rolfing you can lose them up again yes
we with our hands we loosen the
restrictions in the fascia but we don't
just loosen them we also move the fascia
in the direction of more alignment so
that the entire body becomes better
organized and better aligned and what
kind of symptoms can you treat with
Rolfing Rolfing can help with all kinds
of problems in the locomotor system as
back pain neck shoulder knee pain but it
can also be used preventively a body
that has resilient fascia and is well
aligned will be less susceptible to
injury and
paid Rolfing treatment always starts
with a structural analysis that means we
look at the patient in walking and try
to see where has the fashioned and
thickened so please just walk back and
forth here a couple of times and the
first thing I notice is that the hips
are shifted forward slightly and the
upper body is leading back a little bit
that leads to a shortening in the chest
and the head and neck are being pulled
forward and down a little bit but her
problems are located here in the back
here and in the neck and you say that
they arise from a shortage here in the
front path exactly that but that's what
typically happens is that the shortness
is on one side and the other side needs
to compensate that means there's
additional tension there to hold on to
the neck and that's where the overload
occurs and pain starts to happen okay
and now you can start therapy yes okay
that's what we do the first thing I'm
gonna do here is try to reposition the
hips so I bring the knee up and use
pressure of my shoulder to push through
the thigh into the hip and make the hip
go back a little bit so can you actually
feel they share be beneath your hands I
can feel it through the skin I can feel
places where it's stuck or hardened or
where it's glued together and I try to
release those places but not just to
release them but also reposition the
fascia as we try to respect the pain
threshold of the patient
it's very important because if if there
is too much pain then the organism will
recoil and will not open up and we will
not create more lengths but the body
will short
and tighten so it's very important to
take that into account and respect the
limits of the individual person so right
now you're focusing on the poster and
and you're treating the right leg but
still there's some pain in the neck
so do you treat in this region as well
we always treat the entire body so after
having repositioned the hip a little bit
I'm going to go up to the chest I place
my hand under the back here to support
and lift up the chest a little bit and
with the other hand I can now lengthen
the fascial on the front of the thorax
okay we've got a lot of viewer questions
like from Taniya Banerjee from India he
has some pain in his shoulders for about
nine years and ever since he had an
accident and and now he wants to know if
treating fasciae could help him as a
result of injuries fashio typically
hardens and thickens and becomes glue
together and this can develop into a
vicious cycle so that stiffness can
itself produce pain and by releasing the
fashio we can sometimes break that cycle
because we introduce movement and
adequate range of motion and then
sometimes we can improve the situation
even after after years and this patient
can I do the therapy by myself say like
pressing on the fascias and are using a
facial roll for instance it's hard to do
it on yourself with your hands because
often it's places are hard to reach but
you can use a fashio roll which is an
excellent tool for self help it's just
important to respect your limits and not
overdo it so don't go beyond the threat
of pain threshold